and you're doing we want to promote what
you're promoting too it's called my
truth the rape of two Coreys tickets go
on sale this Saturday my truth doc and
its do see my truth dot-com and you're
gonna be talking about it I have to ask
you one question because one one
question I've had and other people have
said is well are you allowing kids to
remain in danger by waiting and waiting
and I don't mind you somebody monetizing
something but ours are the people who
you might name still abusing kids or are
they people who are not putting kids in
danger at this point the problem is a
lot of people just don't understand how
the system works that's really the
problem you know there's there's no such
thing as me waiting and you know this
this hypothetical idea that like the
longer I wait the more kids are gonna
get abused it doesn't work like that the
way it works is I've let me put it even
bolder 90% of the talk shows that I have
done since this all started the host
comes up and whispers in my ear is it
sighs how and I'm like yeah
cuz everybody knows everybody in the
damn industry knows but nobody wants to
be the first to accept the liability
that's all this is about that's all this
is about
and so at the end of the day it's like
looking on the guy that put my neck on
the line I took the risk I'm doing what
I have to do and you know God willing
everything works out I'm not happy about
having to be the guy to do this I don't
want to do this has that guy reached out
to you because he my I said there must
be a nervous guy out there somewhere
yeah he knows who he is or they know who
they are yeah I don't want it I don't
even want to go into that subject I
don't want to go into it but there or
not they've reached out I've got
security here as you can see yes it's
not a joke no reason that he should have
to explain himself he has done this over
and over again but none of the fair
questions though because it to say hey
we're gonna be outing a pedophile a
certain point the fair question is is he
still molesting kids that's that's a
that's a fair question asking me and of
course it's a fair question but it's
also a fair question to say like why is
it not the police responsibility
absolutely look they know yeah I mean
look you did you the interview Olivier's
know everybody knows what was the first
not my job but he didn't rape me I don't
have to do any oh he didn't okay that's
the point is that I'm doing this out of
my heart because I care about a promise
I made to my best friend and I care
about the fact that if if and this is a
big if if this works
and enough people watch this and enough
people create enough noise in the ether
then yes change could happen because
what could happen is then other people
will feel emboldened other victims will
come forward as we've seen with our
Kelly with other cases like this where
when it becomes a news story and a
public thing where it's accepted by the
mainstream media then all of a sudden
it's like okay we better do indictments
on this guy
we better really investigate and then
other people come forward and that's how
it happens and when these other people
start coming forward you get a laundry
list of victims then you have a real
chance at getting the guy off the
streets if you don't lay out the
information the proper way if you don't
put everything on the table the way it
should be done then you have no chance
and I mean no chance that the district
attorneys are gonna go back and open old
cases because all of a sudden some guys
you know complaining and the SOL has
changed the SOL is strictly for civil
lawsuits it's not for criminal so you
want to talk about getting a guy that's
got power and money off the streets
it takes a lineup of witnesses it takes
a great criminal investigator and it
takes a district attorney willing to
start looking at old cases and turning
over stones after he gets new complaints